un esfuerzo desde ambos lados de la
frontera
Estados Unidos y México acordaron un
nuevo plan para controlar los crecientes
flujos migratorios el acuerdo contempla
por un lado gestionar el acceso de miles
de migrantes venezolanos a Estados
Unidos vía aérea como parte del trabajo
del gobierno biden Harris para construir
un sistema de inmigración justo ordenado
y seguro el departamento de seguridad
nacional anuncia acciones conjuntas con
México para reducir las llegadas a
nuestra frontera suroeste y crear un
proceso más ordenado y seguro para las
personas que huyen de la crisis
económica y humanitaria en Venezuela
y volver a México a aquellos que pasen
de forma irregular a Estados Unidos las
autoridades de Estados Unidos comenzarán
a gestionar el acceso de 24.000 personas
migrantes de nacionalidad venezolana por
vía aérea el nuevo proceso aceptará
únicamente a las y los solicitantes que
cumplan con las reglas del programa y
que no se presenten en la frontera entre
México y dicho país el programa
establece unas condiciones específicas
para que los migrantes venezolanos sean
elegibles
tener un patrocinador en Estados Unidos
que le brinde apoyo financiero y de otro
tipo pasar rigurosos controles
biométricos y biográficos de seguridad
nacional y seguridad pública presentar
certificados de vacunas y otros
requisitos de salud pública
el anuncio llega en un momento en el que
el flujo migratorio es de Venezuela y
otros países latinoamericanos no se
detiene dejando imágenes como estas de
10.000 viajeros bloqueados en necoclí en
el noreste de Colombia esta semana por
eso además ha pedido del gobierno de
Andrés Manuel López Obrador Washington
proporcionará 65.000 visas temporales
adicionales a migrantes de diversos
orígenes para trabajos no agrícolas
20.000 de ellas serán para
centroamericanos y haitianos